hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to this quick recap video of
wwdc
2016 apple's keynote this is the first
time i've gotten to go to one it was a
pretty quiet one this year there were no
new hardware announcements but still
some interesting stuff so these are five
things that were announced just so you
know number one is watch os i don't know
how many of you still use an apple watch
but it seems like apple is dedicated to
continuing to improve its usability you
get your most frequent apps in a dock
that you get from the side button and
you also get to swipe up from the bottom
like on an iphone for control center you
can also scribble in handwriting to
reply to messages if you have no other
way to dictate your reply
you also get things like a minnie mouse
watch face an app that reminds you to
breathe but what i'm really most excited
for is for it to be fast this is
literally the demo that they had of
opening apps in watch os 3 versus watch
os 2. and if it's anything like this in
real life then this will be the biggest
improvement to the apple watch in a
while and we're going to look at an app
called one football we're going to
launch it from the complication on the
bottom left we're going to see how long
it takes
so here we are launching the app
takes a few seconds to launch
and then once it launches it loads some
data and it updates there we go now
we're going to take a look at one
football
launching in watchos 3.
are you guys ready
okay don't blink
that's it
number two is tv os nothing terribly
exciting here but mostly just extending
the ios experience to the living room
with more and better apps for the apple
tv there's apparently something like
6000 native apps for apple tv now which
is a plus and they're also going to have
a dedicated iphone serial remote app
which will function the exact same way
as the actual remote did so you can
control your apple tv from your iphone
so number three is mac os a couple of
bigger changes here number one obviously
being the name it's no longer os 10 it's
just mac os sierra and its main focus
was a bunch of continuity features
actually and we saw these in the
beginnings of the last version of the os
and it was looking really useful so the
first of which was called auto unlock
which is the ability to unlock your
password protected mac with a trusted
device like your apple watch so if you
go to unlock your mac and you're wearing
your apple watch it won't ask you for
your password because it knows it's you
and it won't prompt you it'll just log
you right in and there's other things
like keeping all the files that you have
on one mac synced across all your
computers including your iphone and your
ipad so you can have access to any of
your files from anywhere but my favorite
was actually something called universal
clipboard which will allow you to copy
and paste things across any device that
has continuity so you can copy something
on your mac
and paste it on your iphone or copy
something on one computer and paste it
on your ipad super useful there will
also be an update to apple pay that will
allow you to pay for things with your
mac not like this
but by actually using your iphone to
authenticate the purchase so it's just
kind of like a new purchase method it's
like a paypal account or an amazon
account it's a new way to pay for things
online just by having your iphone right
there next to you so that's some pretty
cool stuff with mac os sierra there's
all that and then
tabs
unlimited tabs they actually built tabs
into the os so any app not just finder
and safari but any app can have
unlimited tabs now so number four is ios
we got a couple of new features in ios
as well we got our first look at ios 10
and some of these are going to sound
pretty familiar first of all you can get
rid of stock apps that you never use in
the new ios
so news
tips
weather whatever it is if you don't use
it you don't need a folder just for
apple crap anymore you can actually get
rid of them in ios 10. this was never
even actually said on stage but i just
figured you might like to know that
there's also raise to wake which does
exactly what it sounds like it'll light
up your whole screen and show you all
your notifications just whenever you
lift up your phone and look at it and
the notifications themselves on the lock
screen are actually greatly improved so
first of all you do get a clear all
notifications button on your lock screen
nice
and you can also now 3d touch a
notification to expand on your lock
screen and show more info and they call
these widgets this looks pretty cool for
certain apps that are like showing you a
lot of information in the notifications
and you can also now 3d touch certain
app icons on your home screen to again
get you guessed it widgets not just
shortcuts i don't know about you but i
kind of stopped using 3d touch on my
iphone as much as it was touted as a key
feature my iphone 6s i just stopped
using it but i guess with ios 10 and
these new notification features and home
screen widgets we'll be giving another
shot there are some other features like
an apple news complete redesign in apple
music complete redesign and a new app
called home as a hub for all your home
kit enabled devices and then of course
the emojis
all of the emojis the emojification of
messaging if you will when you switch to
the emoji keyboard apple's literally
going to give you suggestions for
replacing words in your sentence with
emojis just to add emojis to them plus
they'll be three times bigger anyway if
you guys want to see all about ios 10
and its new features i'll link to john's
new video john from tld dropped a video
of way more new features in ios 10 that
you should check out worth a click
moving on so number five last but not
least is siri so she's first of all now
on the mac so she's got her own little
icon she's right in the dock and sirius
also now opened up to developers so you
can use siri to send messages in
whatsapp or slack or just have siri talk
to other third-party apps and that was
actually part of a larger thread for the
event is them opening up a couple other
things like apple maps and other
technologies to developers to plug into
third-party apps which is good i like
that good job apple but all the time
they spent on siri actually really
highlighted a bigger overall trend in
tech which is the improvement of machine
learning the focus on machine learning
and it's like it's a big dynamic topic
but an example of this was the new
photos app in ios 10 will use machine
learning to identify subjects in your
iphone's photos and then the gallery app
will allow you to search those photos
for things that it's identified like
people or mountains or animals that's
something that google was just showing
us at google i o and that's what the
google photos app has been doing even on
iphones already for a while now and
google photos it knows what i take
pictures of it knows the people it knows
the names it knows the places and then
it turns that around with machine
learning to make that useful to me but
that's machine learning and so is the
new apple maps giving you suggestions
for places to go based on where you've
been often or where you've traveled
before so that's also something google's
been doing in google maps for a while so
all this stuff has been brought to a
focus and i like that they're both using
all the information that they get from
their users to make it useful for us but
just an overall highlight of a bigger
trend i've noticed so this whole event
of apple basically playing catch-up in
software kind of highlights the fact
that they are a hardware company first
and that just makes their future events
for stuff like the macbook pro or the
new macbooks or the new iphone iphone 7
later this year that much more exciting
to wait for either way that's pretty
much it thanks for watching again feel
free to check out john's video on ios by
clicking up there or right below that
like button and i'll talk to you guys in
the next video
peace
you